Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. But when you see Jerusalem surrounded by armies, then know that its desolation has come near. Then let those who are in Judea flee to the mountains, and let those who are inside the city depart, and let not those who are out in the country enter it, for these are days of vengeance to fulfill all that is written. Alas for those who are with child, and for those who give suck in those days, for great distress shall be upon the earth, and wrath upon this people. They will fall by the edge of the sword, and be led captive among all nations, and Jerusalem will be trodden down by the Gentiles until the times of the Gentiles are fulfilled.
感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要获取每周独家加更节目、无广告收听、剧集抢先看权限，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区吗？请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。但当你们看见耶路撒冷被兵围困，就可知道它成荒场的日子近了。那时，在犹太的应当逃到山上；在城里的应当出来；在乡下的不要进城。因为这是报应的日子，使经上所写的话都得以应现。当那些日子，怀孕的和奶孩子的有祸了！因为将有大灾难降在这地方，震怒要临到这百姓。他们要倒在刀下，被掳到各国去；耶路撒冷要被外邦人践踏，直到外邦人的日期满了。
Now that was the top geopolitical pundit, Jesus Christ, making his debut on The Rest is History. It was a brilliant impression, Dominic. Yeah, well, that's exactly how he spoke. To add to your roster. Yes. Well, I can do Trump, Nixon, Margaret Thatcher. Churchill.
刚才那是顶级地缘政治专家——耶稣基督，在《历史的余烬》节目中的首次亮相。多米尼克，这段模仿真是绝妙。没错，这绝对就是他说话的方式。好丰富你的嘉宾阵容。是的。嗯，我可以模仿特朗普、尼克松、玛格丽特·撒切尔。还有丘吉尔。
I mean, that's basically covering. Churchill and Jesus. And smugglers. And smugglers, yes. So, Tom, Jesus was right. Jerusalem was surrounded by armies. People did flee to the mountains. And Jerusalem was utterly crushed by the military might of the Roman Empire at the end of the Jewish revolt, which is the subject of
我的意思是，这基本上涵盖了……丘吉尔、耶稣。还有走私犯。还有走私犯，是的。那么，汤姆，耶稣说得对。耶路撒冷被军队包围了。人们确实逃到了山上。在犹太起义末期，耶路撒冷被罗马帝国的军事力量彻底粉碎，这就是……
today's podcast. I mean, that's basically the story, isn't it? People can stop listening. Or am I wrong? Dominic, you're so wrong. I mean, this is a brilliant, a thrilling, terrible, blood-soaked story. This episode is following on from the episode that we did for Easter on the crucifixion. I'm not saying this is a sequel, but it kind of is a sequel in that this is about, just as the crucifixion was in the long run a seismic historical event, so also is this revolt, this destruction of Jerusalem by the Romans. And it's one that far more than the crucifixion, of course, is recognized by contemporaries at the time as being of great significance. So right from the beginning, people who wrote about it said this is a war without parallel.
今天播客的主题。我的意思是，这基本上就是整个故事，对吧？大家可以不用听了。还是说我错了？多米尼克，你大错特错了。我的意思是，这是一个精彩绝伦、惊心动魄、惨烈无比、血流成河的故事。本期节目是接着我们为复活节制作的关于耶稣受难的节目往下讲的。我并不是说这是续集，但从某种意义上说它确实是续集，因为正如耶稣受难从长远来看是一个震撼历史的重大事件一样，这场起义、罗马人对耶路撒冷的摧毁也是如此。而且，与耶稣受难相比，这场事件在当时得到了更多同时代人的认可，被认为具有极其重要的意义。因此，从一开始，撰写这段历史的人就说过，这是一场空前绝后的战争。
Certainly that was the perspective of one Jewish historian. And to the present day, people have said this is the key clash, not just in ancient history, but of all time. So in 1896, a New Testament scholar, the Bishop of Durham, a guy called B.F. Westcott, said that it is no exaggeration to say that the fall of Jerusalem to the Romans in AD 70 is the most significant national event in the history of the world. Okay, well, that is an exaggeration. I mean, the beginning of the sentence was completely wrong, wasn't it? Or was he arguing that because it has this immense theological significance? It's because this is in the first century AD, and as your quotation from the New Testament suggested, this has an amazing significance for Christians. But of course, it also has a huge significance for Jews because the climactic event in this war, the event that continues in a way to cast a shadow over politics in the Middle East to this day, was the incineration of the temple, which was the great focus of Jewish life,
当然，这也是一位犹太历史学家的观点。直到今天，人们依然认为这是古代史上、乃至整个人类历史上最关键的冲突。因此在1896年，一位新约学者、达勒姆主教，一个叫B·F·韦斯科特（B.F. Westcott）的人曾说，毫不夸张地说，公元70年耶路撒冷被罗马攻陷，是世界历史上最具有国家意义的重大事件。好吧，这确实有些夸张。我的意思是，这句话的开头就完全说错了，对吧？还是说，他认为这是因为它具有巨大的神学意义？这是因为当时是公元一世纪，正如你引用的《新约》内容所示，这对于基督徒来说具有非同寻常的意义。但当然，它对犹太人也具有极其重大的意义，因为这场战争的高潮事件——在某种程度上，至今仍在阴影中笼罩着中东政治的事件——就是圣殿的焚毁，而圣殿曾是犹太人生活和……
Jewish ritual practice. And the loss of the temple continues to reverberate through into the present. So I think you can absolutely make a case that the subject of today's episode is crucially important. However, I think saying that it's massively important to both Jews and Christians does highlight a risk with studying the episode itself, which is that we back project that significance onto what actually happened. Yeah, understood. So maybe, Tom, what we should do, I know you want to tell the story and then revise the story. So there's a great sense of mystery here for the listeners, because you're going to tell the story in the first half, and then the second half,
犹太宗教仪式的核心所在。失去圣殿的影响至今仍在回荡。因此我认为完全可以证明，今天这期节目的主题至关重要。然而，我认为强调它对犹太人和基督徒都极其重要，确实突出了一个在研究该事件本身时存在的风险，那就是我们会把这种重大意义投射到实际发生的事情上去。是的，我明白了。所以汤姆，也许我们应该做的是，我知道你想先讲故事，然后再重新审视这个故事。这样一来，对听众来说就会有一种强烈的神秘感，因为你会在前半部分讲故事，而在后半部分……
you're going to tell us why everything you basically said was wrong. No, I'm not going to say it's wrong, but I'm going to say that perhaps the traditional perspective on it doesn't entirely tell the whole story. Fine. You're going to pile on the nuance. You've sold that in a more nuanced way than I wanted to sell it. I wanted to create a greater sense of jeopardy and excitement.
你会告诉我们你之前说的基本全都是错的。不，我不是说它是错的，但我想说的是，或许传统的视角并不能完全道出事情的全部真相。好吧。你要堆砌各种细微差别了。你推销这个故事的方式比我想象的要更有层次感。我本来想营造一种更强烈的危机感和兴奋感。
But you've destroyed that, so that's fine. So as punishment, what you should do now is give us a bit of context. So in the first century AD. No, I think we should actually go back a bit further than that. Oh, this is unbelievable. All right, go back further. Where do you want to start? Well, I want to start.
但你把它给破坏了，好吧。作为惩罚，你现在应该给我们做一点背景铺垫。所以，在公元一世纪……不，我觉得我们实际上应该再往前倒溯一点。哦，这太难以置信了。好吧，再往前倒溯。你想从哪里开始？嗯，我想从……
Those listeners who've heard our episode on Babylon will remember that the first temple had been built by Solomon, gets destroyed by the Babylonians in the sixth century. The people of Judah, the kingdom of Judah, get hauled away to Babylon. They then get allowed to return to their land, to Judah, by Cyrus, the king of the Persians. And they rebuild the temple on the great rock in Jerusalem. And essentially, they live as law-abiding, tax-paying subjects of the Persian empire. And they have been able to preserve their identity in a way that other peoples who'd been transported by the Babylonians or the Assyrians hadn't, because they have a body of scriptures, of teachings, what they call Torah,
听过我们关于巴比伦节目的听众会记得，第一圣殿是由所罗门建造的，但在公元前6世纪被巴比伦人摧毁。犹大的人民，即犹大王国的人民，被强行掳到了巴比伦。后来，波斯国王居鲁士（Cyrus）允许他们返回自己的土地——犹大。他们在耶路撒冷的大磐石上重建了圣殿。从本质上讲，他们作为波斯帝国守法纳税的臣民生活在那里。他们以一种波斯人或 Assyrians（亚述人）所掳掠的其他民族所没有的方式，成功地保存了自己的身份，因为他们拥有一部经卷、教义，也就是他们所说的“妥拉”（Torah）……
and a whole body of other teachings as well, histories of how God had given them their land, of how they should behave, all kinds of things like that, prophecies. And this corpus of texts, what in due course will come to be known as the Bible, enables them to preserve their identity in a way that other peoples had not. So the combination of returning to this land and this body of scripture enables them to trace their origins back to before the sack of Jerusalem by the Babylonians. Okay, I'm interrupting you now. Do they call themselves Jews? I believe they don't. Is that right? They do not. No, they don't. What do they call themselves? So they are the people of Judah,
以及一系列其他的教义，比如关于上帝如何赐予他们土地的历史、他们应该如何行事、诸如此类的各种事情，还有预言。这批文本——也就是日后被称为《圣经》的东西——使他们能够以其他民族无法做到的方式保存自己的身份。因此，返回这片土地与这套经卷的结合，使他们能够将自己的起源追溯到巴比伦人洗劫耶路撒冷之前。好了，我现在要打断你。他们自称为犹太人吗？我想他们不这么叫。是这样吗？他们不这么叫。不，他们不这样。那他们自称什么？所以他们是犹大的人民……
but over time, so in due course, the Persian Empire falls, gets conquered by Alexander the Great. We've done that as well. Very much a the show yeah and so these these people become absorbed into the greek world and they're known as yudai so we judaians we translate that as jews but a better sense would be judaians and i think it is i think the problem with using the word jew the Jews, is that it brings a lot of medieval and modern baggage. There are lots of Judeans still in Babylon. In the Greek period, they start to migrate to Alexandria. Then when the Greek empires succumb to the Romans, they start to migrate to Rome. These are still Judeans because they're still looking to the mother city of Judea, which is
但随着时间的推移，到了后来，波斯帝国灭亡了，被亚历山大大帝征服。我们也做过这期节目。非常经典的一期节目，是的。所以这些人被同化进了希腊世界，他们被称为“尤代人”（Yudai）——我们将其翻译为犹太人（Jews），但更准确的含义应该是“犹太地区的人”（Judaeans）。而且我认为，使用“犹太人”这个词的问题在于，它带有很多中世纪和现代的历史包袱。当时巴比伦仍然有很多犹太人。在希腊化时期，他们开始向亚历山大港迁移。后来，当希腊帝国向罗马人屈服时，他们又开始向罗马迁移。这些人仍然是犹太人，因为他们依然心系犹太的母城——也就是……
Jerusalem. And this is nothing exceptional. There are Greeks scattered all over the Mediterranean. They're still Greeks. There are Romans who were scattered all over the Mediterranean. Their mother city is still Rome. So I think that if you call them Jews, and the title of this episode is Romans against Jews, it kind of gives it a slight sense of a kind of religious war that has been very, very influential, but I think obscures the degree to which this is essentially a provincial revolt, and therefore perhaps not quite as exceptional as we might otherwise be led to think. All right, let's not leap ahead too much to that, Tom. So at what point does this territory, the area around Jerusalem, at what point has that been brought into the Roman orbit? Because
耶路撒冷。这并不是什么例外。希腊人散落在地中海各地，他们依然是希腊人。罗马人散落在地中海各地，他们的母城依然是罗马。所以我想，如果你称他们为犹太人——本集节目的标题就是“罗马对决犹太人”——这会在某种程度上给人一种宗教战争的感觉，这种感觉虽然影响深远，但我认为它掩盖了这样一种程度：这本质上是一场地方起义，因此或许并不像我们想象的那样具有那么大的例外性。好吧，汤姆，我们先别急着跳到那么远。那么，这片领土——耶路撒冷周边地区——是在什么时候被纳入罗马势力范围的呢？因为……
obviously you said it was Alexander the Great and then the Greek world. But then at the end of the BC period, the Romans are the superpower. And Judea, like most of the Eastern Mediterranean, has been fought over by Cleopatra and Octavian and stuff. And it's been brought into the Roman orbit. Before that. So Alexander's empire gets dismembered. You have two great powers. You have the Ptolemies in Egypt and you have the Seleucids based in Syria. And Judea is basically the pivot.
很显然，你刚才说是亚历山大大帝，然后是希腊世界。但到了公元前这一时期的末期，罗马人成为了超级大国。和地中海东部的绝大多数地区一样，犹大也成了克利奥帕特拉（埃及艳后）和屋大维等人争夺的目标。它就这样被纳入了罗马势力范围。在此之前。所以亚历山大的帝国被瓜分了。出现了两大势力。一个是埃及的托勒密王朝，另一个是以叙利亚为基地的塞琉古王朝。而犹大基本上就是其中的枢纽。
So it's kind of endlessly fought over. And as the Seleucid and the Ptolemaic empires decline, so they are able to establish a kind of independence. The Judeans. The Judeans are able to. The Judeans, yeah. And in fact, they become a very expansionist, almost imperialist power. So if you think of a, try and visualize a map. Jerusalem is kind of just above the Dead Sea,
所以它成了无休止争夺的目标。随着塞琉古和托勒密帝国的衰落，犹大人得以建立了一种某种形式的独立。犹大人。犹大人能够……犹大人，是的。事实上，他们变成了一个极具扩张性、几乎是帝国主义的力量。所以如果你试着想象一张地图。耶路撒冷就在死海的上方一点……
south of that region. So kind of the western flank of the Dead Sea is a region called Idumea that gets conquered by the Judeans, and the Idumeans basically get obliged to become Judeans, to worship the Judean god, to live by Judean laws and rules. They also wage war against the people who live to the north, who readers of the New Testament will remember from the parable of the Good Samaritan. These are people from Samaria who are, the Judeans hate them because they are kind of like a ghostly parallel. They also have the law of Moses and so on, but they don't regard Jerusalem as holy.
该地区的南部。死海的西翼有一个叫以土买（Idumea）的地区，被犹大人征服了，以土买人基本上被迫变成了犹大人，去崇拜犹大人的神，按照犹大人的法律和规矩生活。他们还对居住在北部的人发动战争，新约的读者会从《好撒玛利亚人的比喻》中记得这些人。这些人来自撒玛利亚，犹大人非常痛恨他们，因为他们就像一个阴魂不散的平行存在。他们也有摩西律法等等，但他们不认为耶路撒冷是圣地。
And this infuriates the Judeans. So at the very end of the second century BC, they storm the Sumerian capital, they destroy its holy place. So the Judeans are a minor power relative to the great Greek empires and certainly to the Roman Empire, but relative to the kind of the mix of peoples in what you could call kind of the southern Levant. They're a significant player. However, they prove powerless to withstand the might of Rome. The guy who initially conquers them is Pompey the Great. So go on to become the great rival of Julius Caesar. He captures Jerusalem in 63 BC. He goes into this great temple, which is so holy that only one man,
这彻底激怒了犹大人。所以在公元前二世纪末，他们攻占了撒玛利亚的首都，摧毁了那里的圣地。因此，相对于庞大的希腊帝国、尤其是相对于罗马帝国而言，犹大人只是一股微不足道的势力；但相对于你可以称之为南黎凡特地区的各种民族的大杂烩而言，他们是一个重要的玩家。然而，他们在罗马的强权面前显得无能为力。最初征服他们的人是伟大的庞培（Pompey the Great）。他后来成了尤利乌斯·恺世（Julius Caesar）的死敌。他在公元前63年攻占了耶路撒冷。他走进了这座伟大的圣殿——这座圣殿神圣至极，只有一个人……
the high priest of the Judeans, on one day can go into the Holy of Holies. It's supposed to be the place, the presence of the one God of the Judeans, of the Jews on earth. Pompey goes into it. He looks at it. He finds there's absolutely nothing there and is quite impressed. And so he essentially says, you know, fine, pay us tribute, but you can continue to worship as you want. He thinks that the Judean God is worth kind of sucking up to. He basically equates him with Jupiter, with the supreme God of the Romans.
也就是犹大人的大祭司，一年只能进去一次至圣所。这里本该是犹大人的独一真神、地球上犹太人的神显现居留的地方。庞培走了进去。他看了一圈。他发现里面空无一物，对此感到相当震惊。于是他基本上说，“行吧，向我们纳贡，但你们可以继续按你们的方式崇拜。”他觉得犹大人的神还挺值得巴结的。他基本上把这个神等同于朱庇特（Jupiter），即罗马人的至高神。
And as you said, Judea then gets kind of caught up in the snarl that is the civil wars, but first between Caesar and Pompey, then between Octavian and Antony and Cleopatra. And what Antony and Cleopatra do is to install a guy called Herod, who is an Idumaean, so from these people who've been conquered, but he's absolutely, you know, I mean, he is a Jew, he's a Judean. And he rules as king. And he very skillfully is able to jump ships. So Octavian, the future Augustus, when he has defeated Antony and Cleopatra, summons Herod. And Herod says, yeah, I was on the side of Antony and Cleopatra, but that's because I was so loyal to them. And I will now be loyal to you. And so he gets allowed to continue reigning. He's not famous for his childcare, is he herod no well so augustus famously said that he would rather be um he'd rather be herod's pig than uh than his son yes um which is quite a good joke
正如你所说，犹大随后卷入了内战的泥潭，先是在恺撒和庞培之间，然后是在屋大维与安东尼及克利奥帕特拉之间。而安东尼和克利奥帕特拉做的事，就是扶植了一个叫希律（Herod）的人。他是一个以土买人，也就是那些被征服的人的后代，但他绝对……我的意思是，他是一个犹太人，是一个犹大地区的人。他作为国王进行统治。他非常巧妙地见风使舵。因此，未来的奥古斯都——屋大维在击败安东尼和克利奥帕特拉后，召见了希律。希律说：“没错，我以前是站在安东尼和克利奥帕特拉那边的，但那是因为我对他们太忠诚了。而现在我会对你忠诚。”于是他被允许继续统治。他可不是以擅长育儿闻名的，对吧？希律？没有。所以奥古斯都曾有句名言，说他宁愿做……宁愿做希律的猪，也不愿做……不做他的儿子。是的。这真是一个绝妙的笑话。
so yes and so herod is a very brutal but effective king he's a he's a great builder so he he he develops the temple he builds it on a stupefying scale so that it's installed as one of the great wonders of the entire Mediterranean world. And it remains what it's always been, the great focus for Judean loyalty. Pilgrims come from across the Judean world. They pay money to it, so it's very wealthy. But it's also an object of great admiration for non-Jews, for Gentiles, as they're called. Herod also develops an overtly Roman city on the coast, which he calls, with kind of unctuous civility, Caesarea. Caesarea, I was about to guess, Caesarea, yeah. And he also develops a palace out in the Idumean Desert on a great great rock called masada okay and i think that will be
所以，是的，希律是一个非常残暴但有效的国王。他是个伟大的建设者，所以他扩建了圣殿，其规模令人瞠目结舌，使其成为整个地中海世界的一大奇迹。它依然是它一直以来的那样，是犹大人民效忠的核心焦点。朝圣者从犹大世界的各地赶来。他们向圣殿进献钱财，因此它非常富有。但它也成了非犹太人——也就是所谓的外邦人——极度赞赏的对象。希律还在海岸边开发了一座公开的罗马城市，并带着一种谄媚的礼貌，将其命名为恺撒利亚（Caesarea）。恺撒利亚，我正要猜这个呢，恺撒利亚，是的。他还在以土买沙漠的一块巨大磐石上建造了一座宫殿，名叫马萨达（Masada）。好的，我想这会在……
uh playing a part in the rest of this episode it will so this is a palace not a citadel not a castle it's it's a palace up on a rock it has right around it but yeah there are a pair of palaces there um so herod dies in uh 4 bc probably and And Augustus then divides up his kingdom because none of Herod's sons are really quite a measure up to scratch. This doesn't really work out. So what then happens is that direct rule is imposed on Judea itself. From Rome. From Rome. So they send out administrators, whether this is a separate province or whether it's a part of
本集节目的其余部分中发挥作用。确实如此。所以这是一座宫殿，不是城堡，也不是要塞，它是一座建在岩石上的宫殿，周围有……是的，那里有一对宫殿。所以希律大约在公元前4年去世，奥古斯都随后拆分了他的王国，因为希律的儿子们没有一个真正够格的。这并没有真正行得通。于是接下来发生的事情是，犹大本身被实施了直接统治。来自罗马的统治。来自罗马。所以他们派出了行政长官，至于这究竟是一个独立的行省，还是属于……
the larger province of Syria is much contested. I don't think it's a separate province. I think it's this kind of subdivision of Syria, and this is for reasons that we'll come to later. But essentially, part of the problem for the Romans and indeed for the Judeans is that the Romans can never quite decide what they should do with Judea, how they should rule it. Should it be ruled by kind of puppet kings? Should it be ruled by the priests who, you know, are so influential because of the power of the temple? Should it be ruled directly by Roman prefects and procurators? And they keep kind of changing their minds. So, you know, kings come in, they get moved out, they get kind of bits get chopped off and given to them, get removed, get given back to the kind of central Roman apparatus for control. So it's a muddle and a snarl.
更大叙利亚行省的一部分，一直有着很大的争议。我不认为它是一个独立的行省。我认为它是叙利亚的一个某种行政区划，这其中的原因我们稍后会讲到。但本质上，罗马人和犹大人的部分问题在于，罗马人永远无法彻底决定他们应该对犹大做些什么，应该如何统治它。究竟该由傀儡国王来统治？还是该由因圣殿权力而极具影响力的祭司阶层来统治？抑或是由罗马总督和财务官直接统治？他们一直在改变主意。所以，国王们上台了，又被撤换了，某些领土被割走并交给了他们，然后又被收回，重新归入罗马中央控制机构的麾下。所以这是一团乱麻。
And Tom, where does Pontius Pilate fit in? He's an administrator sent out by the Romans, presumably. by Caesar. So he's been sent by Tiberius. And he's a very effective administrator. He stays there for quite a long time. And interestingly, he's basically very pro-Judean. He builds an aqueduct for the people of Judea. He absolutely kind of respects the traditions of the temple. When he tries to introduce, he tries to introduce to put an eagle up on the temple and the Judeans complain, he immediately takes it down. And in fact, the reason that he gets recalled is that he is so pro-Judean that he's launched an attack on the Sumerians who are still kind of grumbling and discontented up to the north. So he's kind of one of those people who's gone native a little bit. He's so enlightened that he's...
那么汤姆，本丢·彼拉多（Pontius Pilate）在其中扮演什么角色？他显然是罗马人派出的行政官员。由提比留（Tiberius）派遣的。他是一个非常高效的行政官。他在那里待了相当长的一段时间。有趣的是，他基本上非常亲犹太人。他为犹大人民修建了一条引水渠。他绝对尊重圣殿的传统。当他试图引入……试图在圣殿上放置一只鹰雕像而犹太人抱怨时，他立即把它撤了下来。事实上，他被召回的原因是他太亲犹太人了，以至于对那些在北部仍然满腹牢骚和不满的撒玛利亚人发动了进攻。所以他基本上是那种有点“同化于当地”的人。他是如此开明，以至于……
I wouldn't call him enlightened, but essentially the Romans are backing the Judeans as the local big power. Okay. So the Romans are all about dividing and ruling, and there are all these kind of different cultural, ethnic fracture lines in the region. And so they pick on one grouping to back, and basically they back Jerusalem. And that's what Pontius Pilate does. However, as the decades go by,
我不会称他为开明，但本质上，罗马人是在支持犹太人作为当地的大势力。好吧。所以罗马人的核心策略就是分而治之，该地区存在着各种不同的文化、种族断层线。因此他们挑选了一个集团来进行支持，基本上他们支持的是耶路撒冷。这也是本丢·彼拉多所做的。然而，随着数十年的流逝……
tensions seem to develop. There are clearly Judeans who deeply resent Roman rule. Some of these seem to have gone out into the deserts. They seem to have been preparing for the end of the world, for the coming of a Messiah. And of course, the most famous groupings of Judeans who thought this are the people who gather around the figure of Jesus. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip,
紧张局势似乎在不断升级。很明显，有些犹太人对罗马的统治深恶痛绝。其中一些人似乎逃到了沙漠里。他们似乎在为世界末日的到来、为弥赛亚的降临做准备。当然，最著名的持有这种想法的犹太人群体，就是聚集在耶稣周围的那些人。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《娱乐的余烬》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论、八卦猛料……
and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. So, Tom, a question. Why do they resent Roman rule? And does that make them different from other occupied people? Let's say the people in Spain, the people in Gaul, the people in North Africa.
在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、加更节目以及现场门票的抢先购买权，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。那么，汤姆，有个问题。他们为什么怨恨罗马统治？这使他们与其他被占领的人民有何不同？比方说，西班牙人、高卢人、北非人。
Are they different? Or does everybody resent Roman rule and we only think about the Jews because of the subsequent kind of theological history? Let's come to the second part of that question later because it's absolutely the key question. It's the key question. Is the resentment that Judeans feel against Roman rule something exceptional or is it something you would find across the empire? Why do they feel resentment because they're heavily taxed i mean that's ultimately the reason i think it is also clearly the case that um judeans have a sense that um the culture of and it's not necessarily Rome, it's more Greece, is attractive and appealing
他们有什么不同吗？还是说所有人都在怨恨罗马统治，而我们只因为随后的某种神学历史才会想到犹太人？让我们把这个问题的第二部分留到后面再讲，因为这绝对是核心问题。这是最关键的问题。犹太人对罗马统治的怨恨是某种特殊的现象，还是你在整个帝国各地都能发现的普遍现象？他们为什么感到怨恨？因为他们税负沉重，我的意思是这最终是原因所在。我也认为很明显的一点是……犹太人有一种感觉，那就是……希腊文化——并不一定是罗马文化，更多是希腊文化——既有吸引力、迷人……
and dangerous. So, I mean, if you wanted to draw a modern parallel, you could say, maybe the way that, say, in Muslim countries today, Muslims respond to Western culture. There are lots who kind of identify with it. Equally, there are lots, particularly perhaps on the ground, who profoundly resent it. So what you see, so above Samaria, you have the region of Galilee, which is where Jesus comes from, and in the Gospels is presented pretty much as being exclusively Judean, but it isn't. There are Greek cities all over the place.
又充满危险。所以，如果你想画一个现代的类比，你可以说，也许就像今天穆斯林国家中的穆斯林对西方文化的反应一样。有很多人认同它。同样，也有很多人，特别是底层民众，对此感到深深的怨恨。所以你所看到的——在撒玛利亚上方，有加利利（Galilee）地区，也就是耶稣的出生地，在《福音书》中，它几乎被呈现为完全由犹太人组成，但其实并非如此。到处都是希腊城市。
And what you see there in the archaeological evidence is it would seem a conscious rejection by Jewish families, Judean families of Greek or Roman style pottery. So in Judean households, you don't get the kind of pottery that you get in Greek or Roman cities. And that seems to be a kind of conscious cultural rejection. So it's almost like a sort of, to use your modern parallel, it's like a kind of anti-globalization, let's celebrate our own, you know, that kind of. Yeah, a bit, a bit.
你在那里的考古证据中看到的是，犹太家庭似乎有意识地拒绝希腊或罗马风格的陶器。因此在犹太人的家庭里，你找不到你在希腊或罗马城市里能找到的那种陶器。这似乎是一种有意识的文化抗拒。所以这几乎有点像一种……用你刚才的现代类比来说，就像是一种反全球化，让我们赞美我们自己的文化，诸如此类的情绪。是的，有点，有点。
Now, the question is, are these tensions, are these kind of blend of resentment of taxation and kind of apocalyptic yearnings and talk of messiahs and all that kind of stuff, is that sufficient to explain what then happens in the 60s? And I think we should come to that in due course. So I'll just say what happens in the 60s. What happens in the 60s what happens in the 60s is that judea explodes the spring of 66 there's been a procurator who's been sent out by nero this procurator has basically been sent to try and screw as much money as he possibly can out of the judeans because two years late two years previously rome had burnt down in the great fire yeah and nero needs money
现在的问题是，这些紧张局势——这些对税收的怨恨、末世论的渴望、对弥赛亚的讨论以及所有这些乱七八糟的事情的混合体——是否足以解释接下来在公元60年代发生的事情？我想我们应该在适的时候讨论这个问题。所以我先讲讲公元60年代发生了什么。公元60年代发生了什么？公元60年代发生的事情是，犹大爆发了。公元66年春，尼禄（Nero）派去了一位总督，这位总督基本上是被派来试图从犹太人身上榨取尽可能多的钱财，因为两年后……两年前，罗马在大火中被焚毁了。是的，尼禄需要钱……
to redevelop the guy who gets sent out is a guy called geseus floris which is one of those kind of brilliant roman names that sounds like it should be from life of brian and he is um he's an associate of papaya sabina nero's wife and and deep love it uh And he comes out with the personal backing of Nero to raise as many taxes as he possibly can. In the spring of 66, a revolt explodes in Jerusalem against this. The garrison that the Romans have in Jerusalem is slaughtered. And this essentially binds the people of jerusalem to rebellion against rome yeah because they know there'll be a frightening place to be in and sure enough um that's that that that autumn the governor of syria a guy called gaius cestius gallus leads uh a large army comprising a couple of legions down to Jerusalem. The legions are the most effective
来重建城市。被派去的人名叫杰苏斯·弗洛里斯（Gessius Florus），这是一个听起来像是出自《布莱恩的一生》（Life of Brian）中的那种绝妙的罗马名字。他是尼禄的妻子波培娅·萨比娜（Poppaea Sabina）的亲信，并且深受其喜爱……他带着尼禄的亲自授意来到这里，目的是尽可能多地征收税款。公元66年春天，耶路撒冷爆发了针对此事的起义。罗马驻耶路撒冷的一千多人的守军遭到屠杀。这基本上把耶路撒冷的人民死死绑在了反抗罗马的战车上，是的，因为他们知道留给他们的将是一个可怕的结局。果不其然，那年秋天，叙利亚总督盖乌斯·塞斯蒂乌斯·加卢斯（Gaius Cestius Gallus）率领一支庞大的军队——包括好几个军团——南下直奔耶路撒冷。这些军团是世界上有史以来最有效的……
fighting force that the world has ever seen. They are highly trained. They are possessed with siege weapons, towers, particularly artillery, which has a kind of devastating impact. So people in Jerusalem are terrified. Gallus arrives in Jerusalem and Jerusalem is kind of built on, the walls are built on very, very kind of deep ravines, except in the north. And so that's where Gallus attacks. He forces his way through the outer wall. There are two further walls beyond, but rather than attack them gallus then withdraws and he withdraws through a pass called the beth haron pass and there he's ambushed and his army's wiped out and this is the worst disaster that roman arms has suffered since the um the annihilation of varus's legions by the Germans in the Teutoburger Forest.
战斗力量。他们训练有素。他们配备了攻城武器、塔楼，特别是具有毁灭性打击力的火炮。因此耶路撒冷的人民吓坏了。加卢斯抵达耶路撒冷，耶路撒冷的城墙除了北部以外，都建立在非常非常深的峡谷之上。所以加卢斯选择了从北部进攻。他强行突破了外墙。外面还有两道城墙，但加卢斯没有继续进攻，而是选择了撤退。他通过一个名为伯和仑（Beth Horon）的隘口撤退，结果在那里遭到伏击，全军覆没。这是自瓦鲁斯（Varus）的军团在条顿堡森林（Teutoburger Forest）被日耳曼人消灭以来，罗马军队遭受的最惨重的灾难。
And this absolutely means that the Roman war machine is going to now demand a brutal vengeance. So essentially, everybody who's been involved in that, whether it's been the massacre of the Roman garrison in Jerusalem in the spring, or the ambush of the Roman expeditionary force in the past, going down from Jerusalem down to the lowlands on the coast they are all that you know that their hands died in Roman blood and that means that that Rome is absolutely going to demand a terrifying vengeance Tom quick question never in history up to this point has anybody successfully rebelled against the Romans right I mean there's no precedent for
这绝对意味着罗马的战争机器现在将展开残酷的复仇。因此基本上，所有卷入其中的人——无论是春天在耶路撒冷屠杀罗马守军的人，还是在从耶路撒冷撤往沿海低地隘口伏击罗马远征军的人——他们的手上都沾满了罗马人的鲜血，这意味着罗马绝对会要求进行一场骇人听闻的复仇。汤姆，问个快问题。在历史上，直到这个时间点，从来没有谁成功反抗过罗马对吧？我的意思是，这没有什么先例……
the Germans have the The Germans did. But was that a rebellion or was that just resisting? Yes, that was kind of a rebellion. I mean, the Romans thought that they constituted a province. And the Germans didn't agree. The Germans didn't agree. But you see, in the wake of that, the reprisals that the Romans brought to Germany were devastating. I mean, they waged kind of genocidal scale wars against the German tribes. And the only reason they didn't constitute a province was that they felt that it wasn't worth it. But Judea is worth it because it's strategically very important. Judea is rich. Yeah, richer. Yeah. And it's this absolutely
日耳曼人有过。但那算是一场起义，还只是一种抵抗？是的，那算是一种起义。我的意思是，罗马人认为日耳曼人构成了一个行省。但日耳曼人不同意。日耳曼人不同意。但你看，在那之后，罗马人对日耳曼地区进行的报复是毁灭性的。我的意思是，他们对日耳曼部落发动了近乎种族灭绝规模的战争。他们之所以没有将其设为一个行省，唯一的原由是他们觉得不值得。但犹大是值得的，因为它的战略地位非常重要。犹大很富裕。是的，更富裕。是的。而且它是这个绝对……
kind of crucial hinge. So you can't have a Roman province in Syria and Egypt and not have Judea. But I mean, quite aside from that, it's the insult to Roman prestige. It means that there is absolutely no alternative and no Roman would ever think otherwise except to absolutely crush the rebels into the dust. And the Judeans who have defeated Gallus and revolted, do we know what they are thinking? Do they think we could carry this off?
至关重要的枢纽。所以你不可能在叙利亚和埃及拥有罗马行省，却没有犹大。但除此之外，这也是对罗马威严的侮辱。这意味着绝对没有别的选择，任何罗马人也不会作其他想，除了把反叛者彻底碾为齑粉。而那些击败了加卢斯并起义的犹太人，我们知道他们在想什么吗？他们觉得自己能成功吗？
We could beat the Romans and become independent? Or is it this sort of doomed, fatalistic struggle against overwhelming odds? Well, the Judeans are like a bunch of ferrets in a sack. So the rebels all hate each other. They're of kind of various different factions, depending on whether they are from Galilee, or whether they're from Id Idumea or whether they're from central Judea, whether they're upper class or lower class, whether they are of the priestly class or not. On top of that, you have large, large numbers of Jews, of Judeans who absolutely side with Rome. So the most notable of these is um the local king herod agrippa um who has a kind of tranche of lands that's not actually within judea but kind of on the margins of it but has a kind of personal responsibility for the administration of the temple and so before the revolt breaks out he turns up and he can sense
我们能击败罗马并获得独立吗？还是这只是一种在压倒性优势面前宿命般的、注定失败的挣扎？好吧，犹太人就像一袋子雪貂。所有的叛军都互相仇恨。他们分属于不同的派系，取决于他们是来自加利利，还是来自以土买，或是来自犹大中心地区；取决于他们是上层阶级还是下层阶级；取决于他们是否属于祭司阶层。除此之外，还有大量、大量的犹太人——犹大地区的人——坚定地站在罗马一边。所以其中最显眼的人物是……
the way that things are going and he says guys you mustn't do this this is insane who do you think you are look at the power of Rome. Look at all the people that she has conquered. Just don't go there. And Herod Agrippa and his sister, Berenice, with whom he's said to have had an incestuous affair, they see themselves absolutely as kind of devout Judeans, people who are pledged to the upkeep of the temple, but also loyal servants of Rome. And there are lots of people across Judea, you know,
当地的国王希律·阿格里帕（Herod Agrippa），他拥有的一块领地实际上不在犹大境内，而是在犹大的边缘，但他对圣殿的管理负有某种个人责任。所以在起义爆发前，他赶了过来，他能感觉到……事情的发展方向，他说：“伙计们，你们绝不能这么做，这太疯狂了。你们以为自己是谁？看看罗马的力量。看看她征服过的所有人。千万别趟这浑水。”希律·阿格里帕和他的妹妹贝勒尼斯（Berenice）——据说两人曾有过乱伦关系——他们绝对把自己视为虔诚的犹太人，宣誓要维护圣殿，但同时也是罗马忠实的仆人。犹大各地有很多人……
whose interests have been tied up with Roman rule, who think this is a terrible thing. So it's a very, very, it's a very vociferous state of affairs. There are lots of rivalries. There is in no sense a kind of united front. You know, this is very kind of Judean people's front or people's front of Judea. These are people who do all hate each other. So they're all busy squabbling. Meanwhile, the Romans are getting ready to reconquer it. And Nero is still emperor
他们的利益与罗马的统治紧密相连，他们认为这是一件可怕的事。所以这是一个非常、非常喧嚣的局势。存在着许多派系斗争。根本没有什么统一战线。你知道，这非常像是“犹太人民阵线”或者“犹太人人民阵线”。这群人互相仇恨。所以他们都在忙着争吵内讧。与此同时，罗马人正准备重新征服这里。尼禄当时仍然是皇帝……
at this point. And so he appoints a guy called Vespasian, who is not of, you know, the reason that Nero appoints Vespasian is that he's going to hand over a large number of battle-hardened legions to him. And he doesn't want anyone who might in any way be a threat to him. Vespasian is a relatively humble stock. He's from kind of farmland out beyond Rome. He's a very proficient soldier. He's pretty dull. He has a kind of very coarse sense of humor. He has the expression, as someone says, of someone,
所以他任命了一个叫韦斯帕芗（Vespasian）的人。尼禄之所以任命韦斯帕芗，是因为他要向韦斯帕芗移交大量身经百战的军团。而且他不想找任何可能对自己构成威胁的人。韦斯帕芗出身相对卑微。他来自罗马城外的一片农田。他是一个非常精干的军人。他挺沉闷的。他有一种非常粗俗的幽默感。正如某人所说，他总是带着一种表情……
he always looks as if he's having a straining for a shit. It's the phrase that one person uses to describe his expression. But he's popular with his men and he's very effective. And he moves into Galilee and he annexes it. He essentially takes it very, very easily. There isn't much resistance. The main focus of resistance is a town called Jotapata, which is commanded by a nobleman
他看起来总是像在大便时在用力憋气。这是某人用来形容他表情的一句话。但他深受手下士兵爱戴，而且非常高效。他开进加利利并将其吞并。他极其、极其轻松地占领了这里，没有遇到太多抵抗。抵抗的主要中心是一个叫约塔帕塔（Jotapata）的城镇，由一个出身祭司阶层的贵族指挥……
of kind of priestly background called Yusuf, who is the son of Matthew. And they hold out, then the Romans storm it. Yusuf will later tell a story about how all the resistors decided that they'd all commit suicide and they'd each take it in turn. You know, one person would kill another, then so it would go on. And he and one other are left and they decide that they'll surrender. And he is laden down with chains, brought into the presence of Vespasian.
名叫约瑟夫（Yusuf），是马太的儿子。他们坚守阵地，随后罗马人发起了强攻。约瑟夫后来讲述了一个故事，说当时所有的抵抗者决定集体自杀，他们轮流来。你知道，一个人杀死另一个人，就这样循环下去。最后只剩下他和另外一个人，于是他们决定投降。他被套上沉重的锁链，带到了韦斯帕芗面前。
And Yosef says to Vespasian, you are going to become Caesar. It has been prophesied in our scriptures. And Vespasian, he's kind of torn between the skepticism of a guy who's come up from peasant stock and an absolute gullibility. And he's kind of intrigued, but not sufficiently intrigued to let Yusuf go. So Yusuf gets chained up and taken away with all the other prisoners. And the campaign continues. However, what then happens is that in the summer of 68, Nero is toppled and commits suicide. And the Roman Empire implodes into civil war.
约瑟夫对韦斯帕芗说：“你将成为恺撒。这是我们经卷中预言过的。”而韦斯帕芗则在农民出身之人的怀疑态度和绝对的轻信之间摇摆不定。他觉得有点好奇，但还没好奇到放过约瑟夫的地步。所以约瑟夫被戴上锁链，和其他俘虏一起被带走了。战役仍在继续。然而，接下来的事情是，在公元68年夏天，尼禄被推翻并自杀身亡。罗马帝国陷入了内战的深渊。
And in AD 69, it's called the Year of Four Emperors. Yes, of course. And the person who emerges from the Year of Four Emperors as Caesar is none other than Vespasian. Oh, so Yusuf was right. Yusuf was right. Yusuf is right. And that summer of 69, when Vespasian decides that he is actually going to throw his hat into the ring
在公元69年，这一年被称为“四帝之年”。是的，当然。而从“四帝之年”中脱颖而出成为恺撒的人，正是韦斯帕芗。哦，所以约瑟夫说对了。约瑟夫说对了。约瑟夫是对的。在69年那个夏天，当韦斯帕芗决定真正放手一搏、试图成为恺撒时……作为其中的一部分，他让约瑟夫卸下了锁链，被带到他的面前，并被极力鼓励去告诉所有人，他早就预言过这件事会发生。我早就预料到了。我早就预料到了。
and try and become Caesar. As part of this, he has Yusuf, the chains are struck off and he gets brought into his presence and he gets strongly encouraged to tell everyone that he had prophesied that this was going to happen. I saw this coming. I saw it coming. And so Vespasian is very into it. So there's a whole, all this kind of swirl of prophecies that a king will come out of Judea who will rule the world. And Vespasian thinks it's him. Absolutely. And so he comes from a family called the Flavians. So Flavian propaganda is very, very hot on this.
所以韦斯帕芗对此深信不疑。因此，有一大堆关于“一个将统治世界的君王将从犹大崛起”的预言在流传，而韦斯帕芗认为这个人就是他自己。绝对是这样。所以他来自一个叫弗拉维王朝（Flavians）的家族。因此弗拉维王朝的宣传机器对这一点非常热衷。他们引用犹大人的预言，称将有一位君王从犹大走出并统治世界，而这些预言的意思就是指韦斯帕芗。
They cite Judean prophecy to the effect that a king will come from Judea and rule the world. And what these prophecies mean is Vespasian. Okay, perfect. Tom, this is the perfect point to take a break. We're in the summer of 69. Brian Adams is warming up. I've been really looking forward to making that joke. We will be back to get into the bloodthirsty heart of the drama of the Jewish revolt.
好吧，完美。汤姆，这是个中场休息的绝佳时机。我们正处于公元69年的夏天。布赖恩·亚当斯（Bryan Adams）正在热身。我一直非常期待开这个玩笑。我们将回来深入探讨犹太起义那血淋淋的戏剧核心。
Yep. We'll be back for the next episode and that will be on Thursday and we will see you then. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
是的。我们将在下一期节目中回归，播出时间是星期四，到时候见。感谢收听《历史的余烬》。想要获取加更节目、抢先体验、无广告收听以及我们的聊天社区权限，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。